Now that we know a little bit more about Chaos as a whole, the Chaos Editor, and what it can do with clothing,
let's get to the hands-on portion and look at creating our very first piece of Chaos clothing.
And to do this, what we're going to be doing is we are going to be creating a flag.
So along with this tutorial, you should have received some files.
They should be four FBXs, one called flag and then flag LOD 1, 2, and 3.
We are going to use these to create a flag.
Now these were created inside of a digital content creation program called 3D Studio Max.
They were then exported with the FBX format using smoothing groups, tangents, and binormals, and triangulate, all enabled.
Then once we have all of those ready to go inside of Unreal, we imported just the flag.fbx file.
Once we have all of that imported, we are then ready to activate cloth paint and get everything set up.
However, there's one other thing I would like to bring up about this particular tutorial.
We're doing this to make this easy to understand and easy to use.
So we picked an easy asset, which would be just a simple plane to represent a flag.
However, in production, this is going to be a very, very high performance option
for something that should be regulated to something like a GPU simulation using vertex position offset or something like that.
So we are using something here to show you the basic operation of it.
But when it comes to production, we should really be using clothing on our characters or our enemies
or things that we consider to be hero objects that are going to be either on the screen a lot
or that it is really justifiable to have clothing on that particular object or character.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor now and I'm going to bring the editor on the screen.
So this is our finished here, but we're going to go ahead and do a file a new level.
We're going to go to our basic and just hit create. There we go. Brand new level.
And then what we're going to do here is right here, we're going to start importing our assets.
So let's bring up our FBX folder here and we're just going to grab our flag FBX, bring that down right into there.
Move this out of the way. And then for import content, we are going to be keeping it pretty much all the default.
We're just going to hit import. And once that is done, you can see here we have our flag, our flag physics, our flag skeleton.
We are going to need to fix this material. So let's go ahead and double click on that to open it up.
And then we're going to take our diffuse color map here and we're just going to set this to grab this UE4 logo here and just hit apply and save.
And that's just going to give us something that will complete our material.
And we're going to double click on the flag to open it up and bring it on over on screen so we can see here.
And that is our flag ready to go.
Now, what we need to do next is actually activate our cloth paint and create our first bit of clothing simulation.
And to do that, we will right click on our LOD zero and create clothing data from section.
And then from the little menu that pops up, we're going to leave everything default and we'll just hit create.
Then once we're done with that, we will need to apply our clothing data and that is going to give us the simulation started.
So let's just pop back over here to the editor.
So we need to right click on our clothing and we need to create clothing data from section.
So we're going to create then we need to right click on it again and then we need to apply that clothing data.
And once we've done that, our clothing will work, but not just yet, because next what we have to do is we need to define how far the cloth can move.
And we're going to do that using the gradient instead of the brush, because it's going to give us this really cool kind of soft fall off from non movable to completely movable.
So we'll have something that looks very, very cloth like.
And then as it starts to get closer and closer to the end, it is going to fall off and give us something that looks kind of like this.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're going to come back over here to the editor.
We're going to activate our clothing paint and then we're going to select this flag cloth zero.
Automatically, our mask is going to be set to name none and the target is set to max distance.
And that is what we want. We could give this a name.
But for now, what we're going to be doing is we're going to click on this and we're going to go to gradient.
And then what we're going to do is we are going to come in here and we're going to make sure we want green on this side.
So we're just going to hold down the left mouse button as we drag down through here.
Now, if you do make a mistake and you accidentally grab, say, something like over here, that's not a problem.
Just hold down control and go over that and then hit control and shift and you will actually erase stuff.
So with that, we're now going to hold control because we want the red over here and got one over there.
So remember, control and shift. And then just to set our gradient, what we're going to do here is in our gradient in value,
I'm going to set this to 150 and then to set the gradient in our editor, we just press the enter key.
And that is going to set our gradient right there. And let's go ahead and close this now.
And there we go. We have our flag falling. So it could maybe fall off a little bit better here.
But for right now, that is some pretty good results.
So the other cool thing that we could do with our cloth is actually immediately test this in a level.
So I'm just going to pull this off screen here.
And what we're going to do is we're going to look for a wind source directional action.
We're just going to put that in to our level. And then as soon as we do that, we can actually see the cloth being affected by this.
So let's go back over here to unreal. We're going to grab our skeletal mesh because we need that to operate on.
So there we go. And then we're going to look for our wind. There's our wind directional source.
And we're just going to set this to like a value of five and five.
And we do need to hit alt s or simulate to get this to work.
And then if we grab that wind directional source, we kind of like move it around in here.
You can see here it is going to be affecting that. We could maybe set set some of this stuff up a little bit higher.
There we go. 15 is giving us some some pretty crazy results.
So we might want to do it that high. But you can see here we're getting those results automatically without having to do anything else.
Just simply enable the cloth and then drop it right in and it will work on whatever you happen to be utilizing.
So while this is very, very cool, go ahead and stop this.
There is one other thing that we need to do to make cloth run efficiently, and that is add level of details.
Now, level of details are going to be required no matter what version of clothing you are using.
And there are a couple of ways that you can create them.
We can have the editor automatically create the level of details for us, or we can create the level of details in our DCC and bring them over manually.
And that's what we're doing in this particular case.
In our case, what we're going to be doing now is we're going to be importing our premade level of detail one, two and three.
This is you can see here. So this is our base mesh and then one, two and three.
And it's just simply fewer triangles in there.
And to do this, what we're going to do first is we are going to go in to our LOD settings.
We're going to do LOD import. We're going to select it.
Import LOD one. Grab our LOD one FBX and then we are going to create clothing LOD from selection.
Make sure that we remap our parent parameters and then we will add our level of detail one.
And then we will apply our level of detail one. And if this sounds a little complicated, that's OK.
We're going to go through this step by step now because the steps, while there are a few of them, are actually repeatable.
And it's pretty simple once we've done it a few times.
So, again, we're going to come over here to our LOD settings and we're going to go import LOD level one.
This is going to then prompt us to select the level of detail we wish to import.
So we're going to hit this one and hit open. All right.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to right click because we see that successfully import.
And we need to actually first come up here and we're going to go to LOD one.
And you should see we actually don't see anything here.
And that's because we need to right click on this and we need to create clothing data from create clothing LOD from selection.
And we're going to create it from here.
We're going to add LOD one, remap parameters and then hit create.
All right. And once that's been created, we're going to apply clothing data and we're going to apply clothing data LOD one.
And then now we've got LOD zero and LOD one.
So, again, what we're going to do here is we're going to come to our LOD import, import level of detail to select our second level of detail and press open.
And then that's going to give us our second level of detail here.
So we're going to right click on that and we're going to go create clothing LOD from selection.
Well, we're going to target asset is the first level of detail and we are going to add a second level of detail.
So we have the base match level of detail one level of detail two.
We're going to make sure to remap our parameters and then hit create.
And then what we're going to do is apply our level of detail to.
OK, fantastic. Then we're going to do this one more time.
Import level of detail three. We're going to select our third level of detail.
Press open. Give us a second to import. There we go.
OK, click it down to level of three here. So now we're actually looking at the third level.
Create clothing LOD from section. What do we want to do?
The target asset, again, is going to be the first level of not the first level of detail, but the main mesh.
We are going to add a third level of detail, make sure that we remap parameters and press create.
Then we are going to apply that third level of detail clothing.
And now what we should have here is zero one, two and three.
And what that remap is doing is it's basically making sure that as we go down the different level of details,
notice that our gradient is still staying there, even though we are missing quite a bit of information.
Basically, what is happening is that remap is automatically applying whatever it is we had in the previous section
to map what is below it, saving us time so that we don't have to go in and paint every single section.
And what this is going to give us inside of unreal is now we're going to have our base.
And then as we start to move further and further away from the camera, we're going to get our LOD zero, LOD two, LOD three.
So let's go ahead and just pop inside of the editor now.
So I'm going to close this. And if we just hit Alt S, we should see this start to simulate.
We're going to see here it is actually doing its LOD.
But since it is such a good representation of it, it's actually kind of hard to see it move.
So what we're going to do here is we can come down to our not our landscape.
We want our optimization. That's the wrong one right there.
Not our visibility. We want our optimization. And I would like to see.
No, that's not the one that I'm looking for. I am looking for.
Let's just go back to lit mode really quick. We want level of detail.
There it is. And we want our mesh LOD coloration.
So this is going to be base. And then as we start to get away, it's going to start to change colors.
So we go from this to LOD one, LOD two and then finally LOD three.
The last part of the chaos clothing quick start is going to talk about where you can find different settings to adjust the various properties of how your cloth is going to react.
This is both reacted to the clothing itself as well as the environment.
So under your clothing, you're going to find these cloth configs.
There's the chaos clothing configure. I'm sorry, chaos cloth config.
And then the chaos cloth shared SIM config. This bottom one right here.
We're going to go over this first because this is a little bit shorter and it will affect how chaos is simulated through your entire project.
So basically the simulation here, the iteration count is one, the maximum iteration count.
And then if we have any in between subdivision iteration counts for sub stepping our physics,
I would highly recommend that you leave these at the default setting unless you have done significant performance testing to ensure that increasing these numbers or adjusting these numbers are affecting your performance.
Basically right now it is set at, well, between one and ten iterations and that is going to give us the results that you are seeing.
And they're actually fairly, fairly good for default values.
Now, if your project is favoring heavier cloth usage and you want to increase the iteration count to two or three,
well, that's totally possible here.
You need to make sure that you have properly tested the performance implications of that because that is quite a big increase in the iteration count.
And remember, iteration is going to deal with how lifelike or how realistic your cloth simulation is going to look.
The next part is the chaos clothing config.
And these right here affect how the material is going to react if it's going to behave like silk or burlap or something of that nature,
as well as how it is going to react to things like the environment and collision.
What happens if it stretches?
If we pop over to the editor really quick, we're not going to go through all of these because the coolest thing about these values is we can actually test all of them.
We deactivate this. There we go.
We come in here, we can change something like the density here and it'll reactivate the simulation as we adjust the different parameters.
Things here, too, are also going to be much smaller values than you might be used to.
You might be used to doing something like maybe like just do 0.125.
Right. And that might not give you the you know, maybe you do like one to six.
In this case, doing things like adding more value like this, maybe we divide by 0.2 or multiply by 0.225.
Adding and removing values in this way is really going to help make sure that you get the best values possible.
Also, there are a lot of different values here that you can adjust.
So don't be afraid to experiment and turn things on, turn things off, adjust and see if they give you the values that you need.
Remember, if you ever want to get back to any default values, all you need to do is simply reset this property to the default and it will reset there.
Other things to look at here.
Collision. This is really important.
Use continuous collision detection if we want to make sure that we have something that is always checking for collision,
because maybe it's inner penetrating something and we don't want that inner penetration to happen using self collisions.
This is detecting whether or not we are colliding with ourselves and then reactions with our animation properties,
you know, to ensure that we are not getting too crazy on the cloth simulation if we are attached to something that is moving.
So there's a lot of really great properties that we can adjust in here per piece of cloth that we have.
So it's really important that we know about those properties and where we can adjust them so that we can get the most out of our simulations.